what's up everyone and welcome to
another Cod Gas live stream here at
anime uproar we've been doing these
weekly they've been a great success so
so thanks everyone for coming and for
being here I do believe we're live I'm
not sure it says we are still live in
the corner right there so it should be
live yeah we're live okay I've also got
the YouTube up and we're live so yes
excellent welcome everyone again to
another coas livest stream is going to
be an interesting one and this one we're
going to be discussing all the biggest
Unsolved Mysteries in the world of kogas
and how they might come into play in
season 3 so yeah let's I look forward to
this and what we're going to do is I'm
going to be taking notes and the best
Mysteries that we come up with we're
going to be featuring in a video so
we're going to be making a video uh next
week or the week after about the top 10
let's
say the top 10 let's say mysteries in
the world of kodas so yeah yeah stay
tuned for that and yeah I'm looking
forward to getting you guys to
participate to share ideas with us chat
with us and then all the ideas that we
come up with together we're going to be
uh featuring in a video and joining me
today we got uh Vector Maximus you know
him from our Discord server we got soul
Maka from the Discord server as well and
he's doing his face
reveal for the first time yeah for the
first time and we got of course Goen my
bro is up guys what's up
Goen up
bro and we got also all the face reveals
Vector got a haircut so that's also a
reveal worth mentioning yeah that's very
important that Vector got a haircut and
I want to welcome everyone in the chat
let me just open the
chat on my
phone go and you can talk while I do
this all right well I just finished
watching codos the whole season and then
Akito the exile
so I'm pretty hyped to talk about it and
yeah I'm all caught
up and I thought actually a a lot of
people hate on it and I get why like
there's a lot of problems but at the
same time it was an enjoyable viewing
experience for me I didn't yeah it's fun
to watch it's just got it has its
problems so it's not as good as the
original definitely that's an
understatement yeah so I mean that
that's my take on it I mean it can be
fun to watch but it's got its issues
exactly the animation was beautiful like
and to fight scenes I want that in
season 3 exactly yeah yeah the fight
scenes are definitely a plus do we know
when it came out akit not off the top of
my
head because it might more advanced than
that we'll
see think it was like
up but yeah my my personal uh thing
about Akito is I feel like the animation
was great and it's useful to watch a lot
of people ask me should I watch Akito
the Exile does it in terms of go code
guos fans like is there a point to watch
it and I would say yes because it does
give us interesting clues about the
world The Wider world of code guos and
guos power and things like that so that
in that sense definitely watch it um I
don't like the writing that much I feel
like the writing was done by a different
um group of people than the original
series and season 3 will be done by the
original people thankfully but yeah the
writing is not the best in O EX in my
personal opinion however it is uh it is
still a decent watching experience and
it definitely does offer us clues in the
terms of code guos world so if you're a
theory buff if you like to think about
all the different theories and things
that um are happening in the world of
codeos if you like to look for clues of
what might happen in season 3 I would
recommend watching Akito and Goen you
want to tell them about the new video
that we have prepared for later today
that's going to be dropping the new
codas video sure yeah we're we're
actually going to be exploring one of
the Unsolved Mysteries which is why
Leila has blue guos so we're going to be
going into that animac is going to be
talking about that analyzing the blue
guos why it's blue and just exploring
the theories of how her specific guos
works and some mystery stuff that's
gonna be pretty fun about obviously it's
blue because it's powered by the the
blue Chaos Emerald I've got whereas the
other ones are all powered by the red
one I was wondering why you were holding
that perfect perfects Emerald that's
that's the also um I looked up when uh
Akito was uh released the first one was
released in a 2012 yeah that's crazy
because like then the animation should
be even noticeably different from that
as it is from R2 so that's G to be be
pretty
crazy I'm excited and it looks like no
one posted a link to this stream in our
Discord so I got to do that now
and shame on the admins I wonder they're
slacking off on their job no no someone
did someone did someone did uh Bita did
yeah but he didn't add he couldn't add
everyone so yeah by the way guys we have
a Discord server link is in the
description there we talk on a daily
basis about different code guos theories
and actually this new video that we're
coming out with today about blue guos
why it's blue why it's different from
other types uh what that means is
actually I came up with the theory while
working on another video and then I ran
and byy some of the guys in our Discord
I believe no digit um Phantom H the rat
and Emperor Lou V brania all helped me
with feedback on that theory so yeah
Discord a very useful place in terms of
discussion and things like
that
um in terms of the Mysteries for code
gas um the main series and akiton all
the different Mysteries that we have
seen to so far in the series I want to
like kind of talk about all the
different ones so like things that are
unsolved that we have to speculate on
that uh seem important but we just don't
know yet we can't figure it out just by
looking at Clues and things like that
because like for example I would not say
that is dead is any longer a mystery
because we know that he's gonna be back
for season 3 however there are many
Mysteries that we don't know yet that I
want to discuss in this stream get
everyone's feedback in the chat and then
kind of come up with a list of the best
uh Mysteries so I'm going to start with
you Vector what are some of the
Mysteries that you um feel are you know
jarring to you that you really wanna
that you really W to uh see resolved or
get some more clues on and Goen if you
can uh keep an eye on the chat and I
will be also taking notes
myself I mean just as uh history and a
supernatural buff I want uh extrapolated
on the nature of guos how it relates to
code you know where it comes from you
know all that kind of you know pretty
standard stuff that we've been
discussing for a while now I also want
the world history cleared up because it
drives me insane as a history buff to
just have these like literally I think
the Wiki page is like three
paragraphs um so that's the biggest
thing I want cleared up is World
chronology you know how it develops and
particularly how guos is intertwined
with it because like there's kind of an
imp that the Branan royal family has had
guos for a very long
time I mean personally it's my theory
that guos was what allowed the Britains
to drive off the Romans but yeah that's
what I want really like you think that
it might go back that far in ancient uh
times yeah I could totally see
it that's an interesting thing because
yeah we assume we see gas used in the
modern day because that's the main Arc
of the story but how far back back does
it go and imagine um guos Power in a
world where there are no nightmare
frames in a world where it's just like
you know sword and and and and shield
that would be even more powerful even
more
meaningful yeah like you could just guos
your entire Army to fight till you die
basically and I mean there's nothing
quite so Savage as a warrior who's with
a fight to the death
basically so I could very easily see
the world history you die or win because
if you just say till you die oh yeah
that could be a problem you you fight
you fight until you win the
battle pleas please don't start killing
your
comrades what's interesting would be to
see if they can actually unlock like
more potential in humans by using guos
too if they could be like you know fight
with you know how our brain kind of
limits
the whole 10 to 15% thing I wonder if
guos could unlock that that would be
interesting like I command your brain to
work at like 75%
capacity if that worked it would be the
ultimate like Universe breaking crap
imagine using that on someone like
Lloyd he's not restricted by that 10
15% that would be
awesome I would be worried what he'd
make the writers can't keep up though
because they haven't unlocked that
potential yeah that's true that's
true and there was a cool thing because
I love chess guys and you you'd know
that me and animac used to play chess
too and I'm I'm a big fan of the whole
game and I love that they played in
codos but one of the big Mysteries as
mentioned in the live chat is how does
the lch Checkmate in the first episode
like it doesn't make sense he just puts
the king like right in front of a piece
that could take take the king like it in
chess analogy it makes no sense unless
the rules are different in the future
for
chess okay to be fair I I I don't think
that's a mystery I think it's just a bad
thing they did for plot convenience
because yeah it's all move is illegal so
it's not really in my opinion a
mystery terms you got you gotta have
some joking allowed it's the same thing
with like the schneizel versus zero
match at uh the forbidden palace like
SCH can't move his King in front of L's
king that's against the rules so I it's
all symbolism and they didn't bother to
study what chess is well what they know
what chess is they don't know the rules
they know what it symbolizes yeah um Let
me let me shout out some people in the
chat we got Lou larouge here all the way
from Australia right buddy uh we got
snto Shaman we got Andy Batista we got
MCG a the anime dude of course is here
what up do at s cyanide blizzard thanks
for joining us bro I thought you would
be busy right now preparing for the
first uh Impressions video but I guess
you're you're still you're still here
backing us up I appreciate that bro Sky
girl gaming 787 says she hasn't even
seen the anime but she's still here for
the discussion so that's cool I
appreciate it but you should definitely
see this anime you should definitely see
Cod it is a good one it is one of my
favorite probably top three so
absolutely recommend it 100% we got
helven he's back in the house Lawrence
kurri Gohan asks how many years between
R2 and R3 and I think two or three is
our current estimate from what we've
heard about rumors uh we don't know for
sure but I believe three is what we've
heard um what who else do we have natu
fired up is here he's been here since
like an hour ago thanks for coming bro
deep voice is here as
well Jo elwin Tristan Mayo what's up
guys jro the hero I love jro he's always
here backing us up in our streams thanks
for coming buddy and yeah so just to
repeat again we're looking at the
biggest Unsolved Mysteries in code gas
during this stream and we're going to be
eventually making a video kind of like a
top 10 or depending on how many good
ones we can come up with um Mysteries
and cod that are still unsolved that we
want to see resolved in uh season three
and Vector mentioned Vector Maximus
mentioned that he like he wants to learn
more about the origins of codee and guas
of course a huge thing and also about
the history of the world of code guas so
yeah those are one the blanks that we
really want to fill in because we know
that codas is our world but an alternate
history so I'm really wondering how
where guos and code comes from and how
they influence the development of that
world as opposed to our own world and
someone mentioned in the chat I forget
now who it was but someone mentioned in
the chat that
the guos uh the witch hunts in their
world were actually Hunts on guos users
or code users like with C2 so that's
also an interesting thing we had witch
hunts you know here back in the 1600s
1700s I guess and in their own world
look they probably were looking down on
guos users as witches right Immortal
witches and so forth so yeah interesting
Dynamic well I think that uh for the
whole witch huntt thing I I don't know
if they were specifically searching
codeos users because you know like the
nun was running well a nunnery it would
appear like so I mean she wasn't getting
hunted and I mean it's quite easily
possible that simply because C2 was
unfortunate enough to live at that time
that she you know she had magical power
so she got thrown in with the rest of
people who were being burned for being
witches so I don't know if it was
specifically for guos but it was
definitely something that they would
have burned people
for well the nun could have been hiding
in plain sight kind of thing well yeah
that's easily
possible yeah it's kind of like related
to the church all those witch Huns so
yeah and Jos Jr has a good question uh
one of the biggest mysteries is Lucha
virgin did
he and did are him and C2 going to end
up together and is there going to be a
lot of fan service in fan in season 3
and I from what I saw I think that Lou
and C2 have been together already that's
my opinion we see them kiss on multiple
occasions we know they were living
together inside this you know the the
student uh Council uh area in the school
so yeah I I think it's a safe uh Theory
to say that uh they've gotten it on
before what do you guys think I think
there'll definitely be fan service and
Akito the Exile they definitely showed a
lot of fan service like maybe not a lot
a lot but like significant amount so I
think there's no fear of running out of
that I imagine that the fan service will
be similar to what we got in like the
the first two seasons
basically you know we we might get like
bunny girl Ken again or something yeah
it's an easy way to to kind of do filler
but not upset the
fans
yeah Tristan May asks Tristan Mayo asks
whether um in terms of the at the very
end of the series do we uh remember when
Colin says that the zero requium solved
made the world P for only a few years
like two or three years but like she
doesn't say it only but it kind of
implies that it's uh for the next few
years uh zum created peace so he says
that this to him is an indication that
R3 was planned all along and I would
definitely agree I think that there's a
lot of clues that R3 was planned all
along there's rumors that code GS was
initially supposed to have 75 episodes
instead of 50 we saw the promotional
poster for the zero requium which we did
a video on uh that you guys probably
seen that seems to clearly show a scene
that takes place after uh luchia's
luchia's death after the final scene of
R2 and yeah so I think there's a lot of
Clues there that they wanted it to go on
that the story was always going to
continue after the zero requium and it
was just that they ended the show
because of budgetary issues Sunrise
didn't have that much faith in the show
and so on so yeah I I think it was
always planned it the question is still
will they be able to execute it well
after 10 years I of course hope they
will but I think it was always planned
to do more what do you guys think on
that I can very easily buy into the
whole R3 was planned all along I mean
zero requium is kind of you know a
little thrown out of the blue I mean it
it's basically the last like what is it
two three
episodes and then it's like yeah
basically it's a very quick wrap
up so I could very easily see R3 being
planned and then being
canceled yeah and my also my big thing
too is and a few people mentioned
Phantom black someone else earlier is
asking about c2's name and that to me is
probably the biggest mystery that we've
seen so far um
like uh it really bothers me that we
don't know c2's name because there's
like little Clues but not enough to
figure it out and if anyone knows of
some clues that I don't know about let
me know but uh yeah we know that there
every time her name is mentioned they
cut off the tone and is there's just a
drop of water so some people are
thinking oh is her name water drop or
tear drop I don't I don't think that's
it I think it could be a clue but I feel
like it would be a real European name
because remember C2 comes from Europe uh
initially so I feel like her name would
be a real European name and the water
drop could be a clue though to what that
name might be so yeah I've been thinking
like I don't know if there's like a some
kind of name in in any European language
that comes directly from from water
drop um but it's an actual legitimate
name perhaps in French or something if
anyone knows and has a good idea let us
know in the chat we'd love to uh I'd
love to figure out at least a good
theory about c2's name because that
personally that's the one mystery
I really want to know like they really
tease you with it Soul what are your
theories on c2's
name c2's name um well I mean if we if
we're looking at um
Reena um then we can see that like her
name could be
completely devoid of
C2 because like uh shiori became the V2
and obviously Shi has no connection
whatsoever to V2 so her name could be
anything really you know I mean it could
be Mizu like water some kind of Mizu
name or it could just be something
um French or Portuguese cuz she did show
up in like the Portuguese Jesuit uh
robes so maybe she's Portuguese but
maybe that was just somewhere she ran
off to when she first got cold and was
like getting hunted down and stuff so
yeah it would be useful if we could
figure out like the earliest we see C2
is in the flashback that she show shows
Louch when she's a child an orphan and
then she's meets the none right and that
clearly looks like a European country
but we can't specifically place it like
is it France is it England is it Ireland
uh it could be any of those places right
so if someone from that scene can get a
clue in terms of architecture something
that points us to a definitive location
that would be awesome we weren't able to
do it yet but in terms of her name yeah
a lot of people assume that the names
are initials so c2's name would begin
with a c because it's C2 however as Soul
Maka pointed out in Rena we know that uh
and this is a spin-off manga from um
code gas called Reena of the darkness
that takes place in the Edo period Edo
period in Japan and C2 is in this manga
and one of the characters shiori becomes
V2 so that seems to suggest that the
actual code carries the name so your
name becomes whatever the name of the
code is rather than whatever your
initials are so it's like there's a code
called V2 and that code passes on the
name passes on to every code user it
does bearer it does not the code does
not itself change based on your personal
name so I think that is the more
convincing Theory uh right now which
unfortunately means that we might not
have any clues in terms of the first
letter of c2's
name but it also means that um Louch
will become V2
yeah I suppose it would mean that he's
V2 if we're going by the whole the title
is
inherited yeah so our R2 theory that
perfectly matched
up but I think they always even even
intended spin-offs for code gas CU they
were clear to make it code guos loua the
Rebellion from the beginning and then
obviously came
codo the exiled and then there's the
other manga so I feel like with this
world they were they were pretty excited
about it and they expected if there's
interest to create spin-offs and then
maybe they just like wanted to you know
keep going and I feel like they always
open that up that's not a surprise that
they have like a bunch of
spin-offs yeah yeah I mean the thing
with the cod as well though the the
mystery part that I'd like uh explored
more is how it seems to um have its own
personality or it seems to take over
their personality like um we see in R2
when C2 locks away a Cod from um
Charles her whole personality ends up
changing she ends up regressing back to
how she was before she got cold meaning
her personality once she gets cold is
different well I personally believe that
the reason for that is that um it's
shown that basically once you get a code
like all your memories from that point
on are linked to that code so when she
lost or when she locked away her code
she also locked away all those memories
and without those centuries on centuries
of just you know increasing apathy at
the world she reverted back to you know
the emotional state that she had before
she had
code okay but there's a there's another
Point um in Reena um I link anim the
page
um there's a part at the end cuz Dash
the main villain and it he ended up
getting cold from U and it is stated
that you was the one who blocked his
code which is really weird because it's
like it means that the code itself then
has its own personality it's like it has
its own
will and maybe maybe G GE works the same
way and that's why like um the the scene
with the euphemia happened because he
was ready to like give up the battle
then the will of the gear was like no
you still got things to
do yeah if you stop trying to change
things now then you know you're going
against the will of this gear and then
that's why it kicked in and then became
a runaway
gear yeah that's a really interesting
point actually that's a really
interesting point I like that because uh
and me and soak were talking about it
this on the Discord um the IDE of
whether the code actually has a
personality of its own whether it
changes your character so that now Louch
if he has code which we believe he does
will be a different Lou than we know and
the question is how much different
whether it'll affect his personality in
some fundamental way obviously Lou we
all love him as a character so it's a I
want you know it might be a bad thing if
he changes or he might just only change
slightly or something like that but yeah
it's an interesting point because
yeah and I actually haven't thought of
that Soul when you said Lous guos
getting out of control just at the time
when he was talking to yui because yeah
it's almost like is the guas taking
control over him because we know that in
Akito uh Shin Huga Shang the main
villain his guos is considered to be a
curse on him that kind of G grabs
control of him he almost he appears to
have like a mental illness he appears
like obsessed and stuff and we know of
course ma becomes a obsessed and goes
crazy because of his guos so yeah that
is a big thing does guas actually can it
take over in some way can it drive you
crazy can it change your personality I
think that's a really um interesting
Theory and question uh Lou lampu in the
in the chat asked if there's going to be
a dub version of this of season 3 there
most definitely is however the dub will
take at least a few months probably like
six months to come out after the sub
comes out so if you want to watch it
first you want to watch it as soon as it
comes out you're going to have to watch
uh subbed 100% so you know if you're
waiting for dubb you're going to be
waiting a long time and everyone's going
to be talking about what happened and
you're not GNA be the you know in the no
so I would suggest watching the sub
first and then when the dub comes out
re-watching it that's what I'm gonna do
well I think it's been five years and I
ain't seen a dub for um aito
yet yeah there is no dub for a that's
correct but I assume like season 3 will
be popular enough but again it's nothing
it's not for sure so I would definitely
recommend watching sub as soon as it
comes
out yeah and I think as well that's why
Charles had um full control of his gears
because he was determined in his goal
with his gears and he never at any point
backed away from that goal I mean he
even like sent his kids away and all
sorts you know for the sake of getting
that goal done so I think that's why
like him and his gears was working more
hand in
hand okay so maybe the original goal
they have the guos has the same goal and
then if they stray away from it that's
when there could be
problems Yeah Yeah well yeah because I
mean that's the reason that they have it
in it so that's it sole purpose in it so
then it will is to fill that purpose
of that that's interesting because that
would definitely explain the you part
that was the one case where I felt like
guos definitely acted on its own to the
biggest
extent and that was weird for Louch to
say though just randomly be like oh it's
like as if I told you kill all the
Japanese and then bam it
happened saw that seemed like such such
they just pulled that out of thin air
the first time I watched it yeah exactly
literally it was only there to move the
plot along and so that we could have
suzaku and Louch really hate each other
yeah although I do like the moments even
though I have problems with suzaku when
L and suzaku team up because it's really
like they can do anything they're so bad
they team that that's kind of the whole
point is that you know together they
could have done anything but their
ideals are so combative to each other
that yeah you know it really
requires the figurative end of the world
impending for them to work together yeah
and the funny thing is like suzaku
abandons his ideals after are like yui
dies to an extent and louo you know he
watched his mother die and and suzaku is
not understanding of that at all
morality pet dies time time to jump off
the slippery slope
suzaku yeah setb 888 asked um let me
just find
it just find
it a lot of stuff going on at the same
time so it's hard for me to keep up with
the chat which is awesome of course it
means there's a lot of people in the
chat and everyone welcome thank you for
coming zanb says what's V2 real name and
I don't know if we actually know this on
the wiki if you go on the code heas Wiki
it says his name is
Victor uh Victor u z
britania yeah but I don't I I don't know
if there's an actual some if it is
revealed I don't know if maybe in the
mangas it is revealed or something I
can't remember it ever being revealed
and I mean just in general the wiki is a
little iffy because I've read a fair
amount of stuff on there that I've
haven't been able to find so I mean you
got to take what the wiki says with like
half a grain of
salt Victor sounds right though I don't
I just watched I don't know I I had
always heard it said as Vincent
oh well there's
V yeah but again Victor if like I I if
it's Victor I want to see some evidence
for it and it also seems to be going on
the basis that V has to be his initial
but we know that someone named shiori
was previously known as V2 from the
renya manga so that means that his name
does not necessarily have to be
Victor it does not necessarily have to
start with a V but yeah so I did see
that in the in the wiki in the code
guess Wiki it's it's given as fact that
his name is Victor Z brania but if
anyone has actual evidence where this
comes from from let me know otherwise if
it's just speculation I mean it doesn't
make any sense like that's like me
saying a c2's name
is
Joanna based on what based on [__]
you Jonah OB the best
theory well she can't be Jon of Arc
because like in I forget with the
nightmare of Nell she was shown fighting
Jon of Arc really okay yeah she she was
like the britan the Brit the English
equivalent to Jon of Arc in the 100
Years War like that's the back story in
Nightmare of n oh
interesting anyway L SL in the chat stop
all caping and tagging me I see you bro
I see you
relax don't miss my chats or
else notice me
senpai yeah Lawrence one two three asks
um why in the trailer we see uh Orange
in water why he and he looks like he's
being attacked or electrocuted
and yeah I don't know um it's definitely
outside he's definitely somewhere
outside so it's a new scene it's not the
scene where Louch uses um the technology
to electrocute him in the Metro station
in season two in the episode where
Shirley dies so we don't know yeah I I'm
guessing that be that someone is trying
to get to Louch and they're going
through orange because I my suspicion is
that orange knew about um either knew
beforehand or knew afterwards that Lou
survived because of his loyalty and he
was one of the people that Lou trusts so
I feel like to get to Lou you would have
to go through orange first so that's why
I think he's being
attacked yeah okay yeah I mean I think
you could be getting a texto just for
his um code counselor or gear counselor
device in his head like they might want
to use it as a weapon or as a shield to
protect themselves from those who've
called
or just in general somebody might want
to be taking revenge on everyone who is
part of luchia's reign as
Emperor I mean it's not unheard of Alexa
asks if uh we addressed the whole rumor
that Louch had blue in his one eye and
this comes from this comes from uh I I
found out about this yesterday in our
Discord server and this is basically
there's a rumor that the PV that we saw
on YouTube like um the trailer from the
anniversary event is incomplete that
there are bit more parts to it and that
those people who were at the anniversary
event saw the full one and that in one
of the parts Louch is seen as having
blue gas in one of his eyes so kind of
like Lea and actually yeah I don't know
this could be just rumors like until I
actually see the trailer I don't want to
talk about it because it could be
someone just messing with us like I
don't know if anyone has actual
legitimate evidence that this happened
but I did in the new video that's coming
out today about blue
I did talk about what I think this could
be if it's true I kind of addressed it
so definitely look out for that video I
am talking about everything we know
about Blu gas there and I do address
this rumor even though we don't know if
it's more than a rumor so stay tuned for
that it'll come out later today as soon
as Goen finishes the editing right Goen
yeah yeah get to work bro it's coming
I'm multitasking right
now
yeah I think one of the biggest
mysteries though I want to see solved is
the uh the
skull yeah what was that that was weird
that was the first time we saw someone
get GS from a
skull yeah I mean I was thinking like
out of all the uh those with cold that
we know of I was thinking maybe it was
Dash's skull CU Dash actually died but
thinking about it he died in Japan and
those lot we in Europe in it so I mean
that's a long way for a skull to travel
so it must be like another code user or
something yeah to me uh that that's a
big mystery I definitely don't one I
want to feature in the video because
yeah if you've seen akit to the exil
guys and again if you haven't seen I
recommend look watching it um the main
villain Shin Huga Shang gets his gas
from a vision of a skull a skull that
just materializes and gives him his
power and the skull has a big uh gu
symbol on on his forehead but that's all
it is so it's not an actual human with
code or Immortal being with code which
is strange and I actually think it might
be related to the collective
Consciousness that shows up later on in
Akito it's almost like the uh you know
because the collective Consciousness
they've moved Beyond physical form and
it's almost like some kind of spiritual
non-physical entity gives Shin his guos
it's almost like these this Collective
Consciousness or some factions within it
if they're can be different factions are
now interfering with the real world and
this is something that is like a big
thing and this part of Akito I
definitely like and I think it could
play a role in season three even though
like I like I said the writing in Akito
was not the best but there are some
interesting issues philosophical issues
and issues about the world of code guos
raised that I really liked and I think
could be very relevant for season 3 and
yeah in this video that's coming out
later today I'm talking about all of the
Mysteries in Akito a lot of them so
definitely check that out if you want
know more about Akito about blue gas and
so
forth yeah Akito brings up a lot of
interesting stuff including the fact
that human consciousness can alter
reality which I think would play a big
part in the next season because that's
an interesting thing like thoughts being
able to alter reality and in Akito they
also included this idea that different
brain waves can sync together and create
like a more powerful Observer that can
change reality so they might play on
that
too yeah Tristan says to notice him I
notice you bro I see you there thank you
for coming I see you all the time you're
a great guy loyal loyal guy um orange is
the color of your loyalty and of your uh
Avatar so that's cool Jeremiah is going
to get upset that you said that to
someone else is he here I don't know he
might be him well we'll see don't tell
him and then if he if he figures it out
if then we'll know that he watches all
the videos afterwards if he's not here
um he asks if do you think after three
years Lou's motivations will change and
he will care more about C2 than Nali and
that's a really interesting question
because actually I think that's a great
point because we were just talking about
can code change you change your
personality like with C2 she seems to be
different when she reverts back to her
pre-code um era now the question is
whether she was just changed because of
the many years she lived with code or
whether code gives you a different
personality and I think luchia's opinion
about Nell in season 3 is going to be
really indicative of whether his
personality changed we know that n
defines his motivations throughout the
Original Series so now if if that
changes it could be an after effect of
something like code if it stays the same
then it could be that code doesn't alter
your personality that much so we'll be
looking out for that and cider Cordo
asks do you think that Akito and Lou may
run into each other in season 3 I think
that's definitely possible like we don't
know if there's going to be Akito
characters in season 3 but rewatching
Akito and doing this video that I was
just working on for today I really feel
like there's a lot of things raised in
Akito that would be strange if they
didn't show up so for example Leila the
main character in Akito who has blue
guas she gets her guos from
C2 this means that she currently still
has a valid contract with C2
so it would be strange to me if C2 is a
main character in in season 3 that Lea
would not be mentioned so yeah I think
it's possible that aito characters will
show up in season
3 if the Akito characters don't show up
I'm going to be quite surprised for much
the same reason yeah to some extent
especially do you guys remember that guy
who was in the green box the whole time
kind of
the uh the life
preserver the husband the scientist
husband of that female scientist uh I
think I think I know who you're talking
about yeah because he woke up near the
end of it but they didn't follow up on
him whatsoever so it would be
interesting if he plays some kind of
role in code guos like R3 just so long
as nobody makes a bigger FIA I'm all for
more
scientists the FAS yeah no
them yeah it's going to be interesting
to see how they W up the play out
right well obviously much like the real
world they'll go from nuclear bombs to
hydrogen bombs so they'll just figure
out the code guos
equivalent
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
and I assume they're just going to be
like you know what everyone's going to
have them or something and then they're
like let's not use it because then the
whole world will explode so then they
are forced to use nightmares nuclear
deterrent basically exactly that's the
only way it can progress at this point
because I mean if it just keeps on
getting bigger taking out continents
taking out Australia before we know what
what Australia's about that would be
bad no we can't Wipe Out the emus
they're going to rise up and conquer the
world we got to see the Australians
first yeah let's see some Australian
let's see like what they're gonna do
that's a mystery too Alexa Alexa asks um
she says that the directors of Akito the
EXA said on the at the live event that
there is a possibility of Akito the exil
being Canon to season 3 and yeah I think
we should assume it is Canon unless said
otherwise because it is an official code
gas production an official OVA it takes
place between this first and second
season so I don't see why it wouldn't be
Cannon unless specifically we're told
it's not like it's not a fan-based
fan-made you know animation or anything
it's official so like unless we're told
otherwise we have to assume it is Canon
um cider Cordo says that he likes that I
say his name in a Spanish ta of course
of course
cloi um who else do we have here Maya
maximova or
maximova what if Louch made a contract
and gave gas to another person I think
that's also possible uh because Lou is a
very much
a someone who wants his plans to go to
be achieved so depending on what his
motivations and plans are going to be in
season 3 if he feels that he can advance
them by giving guos to someone else I
don't think he will hesitate to do it I
think it'd be a really interesting twist
to have um lulou like refound the guos
director it under
him I think that could be really cool
personally just have an entire Army of
guos users at his beck and
call yeah I don't know how he'd do it
though I think he'd do it in his own
style you know I don't think he' just
well it wouldn't be a clone of the
previous one like I don't think it'd be
anywhere near as big but I could see him
doing something on a much smaller scale
like to 10
people
yeah it's just how's the show going to
follow it all but yeah I see I see what
you mean I think he could do something
like that to his um character change
from receiving code because I mean
originally before well after Shirley's
death he wanted to uh get rid of um G
and cold didn't it
so yeah exactly I feel like he wants to
be like the only one you know the only
one with like superpowers but that might
change now that he has code and he can
give it to people he
trusts and we're definitely going to see
more of the manipulating Louch I feel
like deep voice says that he thinks
Shin's gas manifested from utter hatred
uh it's true that Shin hates the world
and he thinks that life is a curse so he
wants to kill all those he cares about
because to save them from that curse and
he's crazy but I don't think gas cannot
just manifest like someone has to give
you guas so that's why it's so strange
that he just gets it from like a vision
it doesn't seem it's not it's
not it doesn't fit with any other
example we've seen of someone getting
gas so that is why I think it's tied
into the collective Consciousness
because if we believe that the
collective Consciousness is
a ancient civilization that moved Beyond
physical form which I talked about in a
few videos we can also assume that
because they created the thought
elevators that they created or harnessed
code and guos for the first time so they
would be able to use it so if this uh
these beings that moved Beyond physical
form decided to intervene in the world
and give Shin his guos it could be
because they were deciding that they
wanted Humanity to be wiped out and they
Shin's whole guos was to kill everyone
destroy the world so it could be them
intervening into the world and saying we
want to we we gonna get people we got we
want to have Humanity exterminated
because we don't want them having gas
power they don't they abuse it so we
want to get shin to destroy them however
we then later in see uh the
representation of collective
Consciousness uh the woman say that she
wants Lea to stop Shin that she wants
Shin killed now the question is
whether um the collective Consciousness
at first when they gave Shin gaos they
wanted him to destroy humanity and then
they changed their mind and then they
show showed up to Lila and said we need
to stop him or whether there are
different factions within this
Collective Consciousness and one AC
wants to destroy humanity and the other
one doesn't so that is an interesting
thing as well because that um being in
Akito when she shows up to Leila she
says I used to think that humans were
not worthy of guos that they should not
have it even at at the expense of them
going
extinct however you might change my
opinion she says to Lea and in this next
video that's coming out I I talk about
why I think Lea is special why I think
her guas is special why it's blue and
why it changes the opinion of the
collective being but definitely
interesting in how that ties into Shin
because Leila's power is almost the
opposite as you will learn in the video
of Shins It's almost like the
counterbalance to shin and I'm getting
tagged by everyone in the freaking chat
guys Lou L perou is asking how we think
that Louch will actually be revealed as
alive in the third season how he will
make a reappearance and yeah that's
that's an inter question we can only
speculate but I think it something will
happen like from the PV we see those
explosions a lot of stuff going down
something will happen that will force
him to come out in order to protect the
world to protect those he cares about
something like that something big
something like an attack something like
an invasion something like that L will
just hijack every television system in
the world and uh wear his Emperor guard
and just you know make a fabulous speech
that's how he's gonna show
up Brienne cam asks what do you think
happened to
Arthur the arar you think that Arthur is
the real zero
because Arthur remember Arthur took the
mask so we think that Arthur is the
current zero suzaku gave up we saw in
the PV he was wearing his other uniform
uh and Arthur is the current zero that's
why he was so agile jumping around in
the PB remember that scene think about
it guys think about
it Goen bro
talk yes amuse the people damn it yeah
I'm just wondering what Lou's motivation
would be because a lot of people are
saying like that it's to protect non
right but I feel like I'd like it to
shift I don't want another season of him
kind of protecting nonell I feel like we
got we got our Phill of that so I want
to see what other possible motivations
he can get that would be interesting to
see for another motivation it's just you
know he put all this effort into
achieving World piece and he doesn't
want to see anyone screw it up
yeah for sure and like World Peace like
it's such a such a huge
undertaking he's been there he's done
that he can do it again the question is
how many times does he have to die
very idealistic in it you know world
please so I don't know maybe maybe this
time around his uh dream or goal will be
a bit more grounded in a sense you know
it's funny because he's idealistic but
he has very like tactical and
maian means of achieving idealistic
goals so there's a lot of like interest
in his character like there's it's a
complicated character I like
[Music]
it okay so kurri Gohan said something
interesting she said that in the game
the code g game which I haven't played
actually and I'm not sure how Canon it
is but is that the one with
Ray yes it's an interesting p uh uh
point because she says that I think
Gohan is a girl uh says that the main
character Ray lost his power after
stopping the Japanese Massacre so could
it be that guos could run out that
there's a finite amount of power never
thought of that because it seems to only
get stronger in the
show no well I don't think it's so much
about running out of power maybe it will
disappear once your goal is achieved in
it because if if if we take in the idea
that it has a will in it a purpose in it
and it's there to serve that purpose
once that purpose is
served what else has it got to
do perhaps if if your purpose is like a
finite specific thing and then you are
able to achieve that then
perhaps guos would like the contract
would be unold because it's fulfilled
however I assume if you're you have a
Perpetual goal like to keep the world
peaceful even though there's threats
constantly arising then perhaps you
wouldn't lose it
then yeah I'm guessing so because to
maintain your goals that's a thing too
and for a lot of the goals people have
they require power to maintain it
too
yeah salmon of Doubt says nothing except
R1 and R2 are Canon well what do you
base that on salmon because if you have
evidence I would like to see it but if
you don't have evidence then you can't
say that official Productions like Akito
the
exiled official Productions of code gas
taking place within the same time line
are not canon it's you can't do it
unless someone specifically said this is
not canon the creators you can't do it
man well even then you have to be
careful because if like one member of
the team if only one member of the team
says oh this isn't Canon and they aren't
like the story writers or something like
that I mean can you really take that I
mean you got to be careful even
well yeah you got to Define what is
Canon because uh some people believe oh
yeah if it's written by the original
writer then it's Canon but you got to
remember the original writer also wrote
counter attacker suzaku and Nightmare
Nali which we know both of them and not
canon because they changed the events of
R1 and R2 yeah but my point is if they
don't change the events if they're
clearly meant to be part of the same
timeline then we have to assume they're
Canon unless told otherwise and like a
lot of people are saying they don't want
aito to be Canon and I understand that
because of the bad writing however Akito
does offer some interesting Clues and
glimpses into the world of kodia so I
think that even if Akito was can and
season 3 could still be really good it's
just it needs to be written well and
unlike Akito the problem with Akito is
the plot being convoluted the character
development being weird with characters
switching sides like so easily switching
allegian in and stuff like that it's not
realistic but otherwise I think uh
AIT to raises some interesting points
like with that being that's the
collective Consciousness uh all that
kind of stuff I feel is interesting and
could be explored further in season
3 yeah
yeah just as a general rule of thumb for
any sort of Canon you know what is Canon
what isn't you take the main at least
for me I take the main thing and then
anything that doesn't directly
contradict the main thing I can take as
Canon until it's Direct directly
contradicted by the
creators that's
fair I mean the fact that Akito features
suzaku Lou and Rolo I would say
definitely it's Canon you
know yeah and and then again I mean even
even if it weren't in some off chance
like there's so much room for
speculation because you know if if they
did it they're using it and somehow it's
going to relate to R3 anyways
but yeah I do think Lou and suzaku
played a very pointless and stupid role
in Akito the
Exile literally there just to be there
and maybe show them in the trailer but
like it was it was not their story it
was just not their story had nothing to
do with him
really see that there we
go go
now I agree that 100% Alexa says the
writer will be the same for season three
as for seasons one and two but she says
that her his projects after R2 were
pretty [__] so she she thinks maybe we
are going to be in trouble in terms of
bad writing well um I don't know I'm
hoping for the best I'm definitely glad
that it's not the same writer as Akito
because Akito had different writers than
R1 and R2 and I thought the writing
there was really the standout bad thing
about Akito the animation again good
really good action sequences good World
building interesting but uh yeah the
whole writing character development
stuff was the biggest weakness so I'm
glad that it's the original Cod Gas
writer and I'm hoping for the best it
was rushed that that's the only that's
like the big thing for me a lot of the
turnovers like with Ashley the character
they do similar ones in coas but they're
not as rushed so I feel like because
there was only five ovas they kind of
rushed through a like a whole 25 episode
thing in what would be like 12 episodes
so kind of what happens with uh milardo
and Gundam Wing where they try to fit
all of Char's story into one uh into one
Series yeah and it feels rushed because
I didn't watch that but I'm sure you're
right oh okay never mind never mind I
watch Gundam Seed but that's that's as
far as my Gundam go watch Wing go watch
wing all right I'm open to that natu
fired up asks do we think that there
will be new characters in R3 but even
better characters driving new meas and I
think there's definitely going to be
some new characters there's definitely
going to be new meccas because from R1
and R2 we know that the mecca technology
keeps evolving as The Show Goes On so
we're definitely going to be seeing new
meccas and I assume new characters as
well um it all depends I think it's
going to be a balance they're going to
have a a lot of the old characters
coming back because they're so well
liked but they will definitely throw in
some new characters as well just for
variety just to show us that yeah new
things are happening things are
progressing that kind of
stuff
yeah and in Akito like some people say
the technology might have been a little
more advanced but they were careful not
to like let's say make the uh the
nightmare frames fly but they made them
like Glide you know so in ways they were
they were went out of their way to make
it a bit less Advanced even though there
were cool like spider movements and cool
like different yeah since it's supposed
to take place between seasons one and
two they can't have anything more
advanced what we see at the start of
season two exactly it wouldn't make
sense if they were all of a sudden
flying in nightmares and then later they
get a flying nightmare like oh my God
that's never we we lost the technology
my Lord we can no longer have our
nightmares fly we regained it yes yeah
but that also would then seems to
indicate that yeah it is Canon because
they're going out of their way to be
consistent with the original storyline
the same world right yeah and it's an
interesting ending I wonder if they like
are they supposed supposedly you guys
interpret it as them staying in like a
gypsy lifestyle or is it just like for
the time being they're just hanging
out I personally would like it to be
just a for the time being but yeah
because it I mean I don't even mind it
because you know always it's nice to see
people just abandon reality and just go
go live in the screw off to somewhere
pull a JD Salinger that's you know I'm
not hating it I mean no I think they
would have to live like gypsies
really s they have to find somewhere
proper in the middle of nowhere because
you got to remember Lucha's face is
known so
animol sorry go ahead I thought you were
no go go go go
go animeholic says do you think Louch
will have a new rival with guos in R3
and I think
definitely unless they come up with some
advanced technology for this one that
can negate guos like a guos cancellor
Mecca or something
uh to rival someone with code and guos
and stuff like that you need someone
else with code and guos and I assume
just because it's such a crucial part of
the story you're definitely going to see
a villain with guas because we always in
in the original series we see Co
villains with guas in Akito we see will
with gu so I feel like yeah for sure we
are going
to I'd be really interested to see what
the implications are of a large scale
guos counselor though like if you can
negate guos in an entire city like I'd
be really interested to see how that
would mess up
Louch or any other person that uses guos
regularly
yeah I like how Victor your your screen
just paused there for a second and the
Chaos Emerald was in the air Oh My
Perfect Chaos Control that's fine that's
that's the current dat right no this is
a Chaos Emerald
I have all the power you have all of
them I well I only have one I Can
[Music]
Dream yeah I think it's strange as well
in um in Reena uh
Dash um he kind
of he he has like a deformed um gear or
something it's weird cuz like it causes
like the ities or transformations in
people when he when he like gives it to
them and those people because they seem
pretty much like mutants they are known
as nightmares so I'm wondering if the
idea of The Nightmare frames came from
them I think it's more likely that they
just ripped it straight from the
original series simply to make
reference yeah because it's in the past
yeah yeah yeah because obviously there
are no nightmare friendes so
yeah because a crucial part of the story
is that Britannia come ups with the
comes up with the nightmare frames at a
certain point in time and that's what
gives them the edge to conquer most of
the world yeah um sir edgelord is asking
do you think Louch is going to give gas
to someone else uh very possible very
possible Tristan says since motivation
has
changed Al don't don't know Tristan
exactly what you're saying there going
to have to rephrase um another thing is
I want to ask you guys like a lot of
people are asking what do you think is
going to happen in season 3 but I want
to ask you guys in the
chat what exactly are some mysteries in
COD gas the original series or Akito or
whatever that you want to see answered
like
specifically uh some Mysteries that are
yet yet on like c2's name like where
Shin Huga Shang how he gets his guos
exactly that kind of stuff I'd like to
challenge you now to uh send me in the
chat because I want to we're going to be
making a video about the top Unsolved
Mysteries in codeia so I want to see
some Mysteries that you guys want to be
Fe see featured in that video so not
necessarily what's going to happen in
season 3 but what are some Mysteries
that already are still left unsolved and
might be solved in season 3 feel free to
drop them in the chat uh Tristan what
he's what he's trying to say is he
thinks that Lucha's motivations have to
change even even if it's just for a
little bit and he thinking about what if
there's something like a um
a constitution or some kind of Divine
Law that cold users or cold bearers have
to uh live by and that's what he's
thinking that might influence a change
in um
L um Maya asks how not only lost the
ability to walk I think she was shot and
that's how she lost the ability to walk
she was shot in the legs um Louch asked
how did Rolo get his gas he got it from
V2 because Rola was part of that guas
order remember those kids with guas that
they were researching on he was part of
that guas order uh that's why he was
working for them against Louch at first
he was spying on Louch remember and C2
was also part of that order before she
betrayed them horribly yeah
all well all gear users with the gears
in the right eye got it from V2 and all
those with the gears in the left ey got
it from um C2
that's one thing to
notice
inter uh Salon of Doubt wants to or
salmon of Doubt wants to see the gas
getting stronger
addressed it was used once conveniently
for the plot for euphemia and was never
used again so yeah um guas getting
stronger is important in terms of
getting guas in both eyes means
that um sometimes it means you lose
control like with MAO you guys will
recall that Mao loses control of his gas
he can no longer control whose mind he
reads so he needs headphones and all
this kind of stuff in some cases it also
means that that is the point where you
can actually get code so remember with
C2 and the nun uh she can only get colde
once she has gas in both eyes and then
the whole euphemia Louch thing he gets
it at just the time he loses control at
just the right time to create that plot
situation where uh euphemia wants to
Massacre the Japanese so yeah that is
plot convenience to an extent but I also
thought it was an interesting twist and
I think that's really kind of before
euphemia before that happens with
euphemia suzaku is a completely
ridiculous character like he has no
justification for supporting Britannia
with what they're doing it is only after
uh Louch uses his gas on euphemia and
she kills the Japanese and then he has
to kill her as zero that you start kind
of feeling sorry for suzaku that you
starts thinking okay well yeah now he
has a reason to be upset a reason to be
obsessed with finding zero and
destroying him that kind of stuff so
yeah it kind of like that plotline gives
him more legitimacy as a character but
before that suzaku is just like how can
you be motivated how can you be helping
these evil people who are destroying
killing civilians ordering you to kill
civilians like it just makes no sense
yeah he he always escapes having to do
like the actual killing but that doesn't
excuse the fact that a lot of times he
says he's gonna do it before he's saved
or he just lets other people do it
around him so it's
problematic
[Music]
F I
mean for anyone who wants to talk about
suzaku's morals just FIA alth Al the
guos was partly responsible for that um
deep voice asks what if animac and it's
animac with a a AK uh what if anak is
the main villain of R3 and yes that
would be an interesting plot twist
wouldn't it quickly be out
smarted I'd be interested simply so we
could see how your guos actually played
out yeah because remember guys how
quickly you could take over the world
Electronics right that would be the
perfect villain in the modern world
right yeah I like how Akito brought in a
hacker right that was cool too like I
want to see if they're gonna make
hacking a bigger deal in R3 with the
increasingly technological world now I'm
just imagining like the guos user among
the Britains that repels the Romans it's
someone with anamax guos and he's just
useless yes that's
funny that would be a useless gu in in
the history although though we don't
know like the thought elevators and
stuff they could function on some kind
of electronic capacity we're not sure
yeah I mean there are all those like
gears shown and stuff like that like
during the whole sort of aasha
sequence yeah and they did have that
weird kind of um power unit outside when
um Maran and C2 first turn up with
suzaku and she's trying to operate the
thing you know why she's in Ana's body
and she's like oh it's dead it's dead
and then she has to use c2's code to
then like open up the doorway to get
in our giant batteries
confirmed yeah so so therefore my guos
is is a thing and some Rohan I think
asked what would be my guos um my guos
would be being able to do what Louch
does but through Electronics so like
right now if you're looking at my face I
can command you to join our Discord
server and be a loyal follower of anime
uproar
Empire I wasn't
looking yeah be totally bugger you
already are you already are oh no oh no
what have I
become go mad from the
Revelation Rohan says yes my Lord
excellent see it worked it
worked Rohan I wonder why they changed
the guos kind of
the look to it in Akito the exil like
when it's actually happening that blue
scene with the veins like with the wires
and stuff like that it's weird how they
changed it in Akito I actually preferred
it in Kos and Kos R2 kind of the switch
that happens rather than this one where
it's all like I don't know it it was it
was not as good in my opinion the way
they maybe maybe it was because it was a
different Power
though maybe but all of the ones in and
Akito look the same and all the ones in
U code GS look the same so and there's
we obviously saw multiple well I guess
maybe yeah that makes sense because Rolo
you don't really see that happening
because his is completely different I
don't think I and I don't think you see
it with Maui either because it's more of
a rewiring in it like if it's Char
changing your memories then it's a
rewiring if it's um Lou commanding you
to do something again it's a rewiring m
and the fact that they're related could
have something to do with it too quite
similar possibly
possibly uh Tristan by the way Tristan
it's animac with a K not a c at the end
because read it backwards you'll know
why but he asked Lou wears contacts to
kind of negate the effect of his guas so
he wonders whether wearing contacts
would prevent you from being affected by
my guos uh no because I'm not wearing
contacts so I
is it just like a special kind of glass
because I don't believe he's wearing you
know the context when he's wearing the
zero
mask so isn't it just like a special
kind of glass that blocks Kos yeah I'm
not sure it's a contact obviously but it
has to be some kind of
glass no I think it's just that he needs
to have like direct um sight into their
eyes like even if they're wearing like
sunglasses or a sheet of paper in front
of their eyes or something it just it
would prevent it from
working so yeah
glass yeah I wonder then if you could do
it through my glasses cuz I'm wearing
glasses but I don't know how well it
works does not work for people's glasses
unfortunately yeah it's just like if I
had luchas I'd just try to command and
then it just reflects right back at me
you'd have to like lower your glasses to
use it like you'd look
weird like look at
me yeah I command
you yeah it's interesting in terms of
how you know blocking gas and how that
works because with some people like shin
Huga Shang he seems to have guos in both
eyes but he can turn it off and on he
doesn't need glass he doesn't need
contacts contact yeah yeah well that's
how Charles was as well but that's
because he had full control CU he was
living by his gear in it so his gears
was working in tandem with him where as
when we get to points where Ma refuses
to kill C2 or Lou starts having doubts
about like the war and rebelling against
Britannia the gears then takes over or
inserts its own will to force them to
continue doing what they
do like for ma it's he couldn't stop
reading people's mind didn't it so that
could have been pushing him to the limit
of like sanity and then the only way to
stop it is to take Cod because then his
power will
go and then for Lou he had no choice but
to make
commands you know because it was
constant yeah
s yeah and one thing one thing that I
want to mention about Lou is sometimes
people think you know he has good
motivations so maybe his you know his
guos power is a good like not a selfish
thing but you got to remember that
luchia's power is to command others to
do his bidding his bidding in order to
gain power so that he can then do good
things for nalii but it's still very
much a self-interested guos it's not
like a guos oh I just want to help other
people it's a guos that's like I want
the power so that I can obliterate
Britannia and I can create a new world
where in a way that I believe needs to
be created right so just like
wants to rewrite the world reshape the
world in the way he thinks it should be
shaped so his power is to reshape
people's memories so the gas is
definitely related to your um
motivations but Lou's motivations are
still selfish in many ways and he also
the methods he uses killing civilians
when he has to and stuff like that are
very much you know not Noble I guess you
could say they're very mchy of
Allen absolutely you guys think that uh
the guos stop working after the person
dies asks like after lch dies with that
girl that keeps kind of marking the
school building would she stop no she
she's still doing it I remember reading
an interview about from one of the show
producers that's like she's still doing
it and it's a real big problem after she
moves back to the
Homeland because she's still trying to
get back to Mark the wall cusing a lot
of trouble he ruined that girl's life
that's the real tragedy
yeah the problem is that um someone
asked uh earlier on the whole residual
effect of gas you know when how Lou says
live to suzaku and whether that still
stays with him I feel like it does
because remember when suzaku at that end
scene when suzaku is like I accept your
guos some people said that they mean
what that means is that Lou gives suas I
I don't think so I think that when he
says that he means I accept your command
to live because often in the show suzaku
feels like he doesn't want to live
anymore the world around him is
crumbling uh evil is all over euphemia
was killed right so and and then when he
feels that he was cursed with this
commandment to live that makes him use
the FIA and kills all these innocent
people after that he really feels like
depressed he doesn't want to live
anymore so when he says I accept your
guos I think what he means is I accept
your commandment to live I will continue
living and trying to make the world a
better place and also with uh Shin's
brother Akito and Akito the exiled Shin
orders Akito to die however because and
we discussed this in the Discord soul
and Vector uh the reason we believe that
akito's brother doesn't Akito doesn't
die is because when Shin uses the guos
on him it is a um akitu is too young so
he doesn't understand the concept of
death and gas has to be realistic like
has to it's a mental power and it has to
command of you something that you
understand so it can't just command for
you to you know
suddenly uh recite a a book word for
word if you don't know that book if
you've never read it so for for that's
why we believe akid doesn't die but
however the guos stays with him because
Shin's guas is both the power to make
people die or that he cares about die or
kill others so we see Akito whenever
he's in a fight the guas activates and
he's like kill kill kill kill right so
it's another example of a residual guos
and we don't know because the Akito
thing doesn't go on for much longer
after Shin's death we don't know if this
will stay with him after the guas you
the guy who used the guas on him dies so
yeah we don't know I assume that suzaku
speech with louo is is implying that the
live commandment will stay with him but
yeah we're not
sure I thought I thought um saku's
speech with that I accept your gear
was about having to stay as zero and not
being able to live as himself or for
himself anymore because he'd have to
like live the rest of his life as zero
and it was that that he was accepting
like that would be his GE you know yeah
because is usually considered like a
curse yeah and that's yeah that's curse
mainly considered curse right so that
would be his curse like no more life for
himself which he doesn't really care
because he lost like most of the things
he was he lived as suzaku for yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what I believed it
was for anyway yeah and not so much the
live gear that he actually um put onto
him although it's a cool superpower
having that live constantly like help
him out and Yeah well I guess not for
him but for people who want him to win
yeah well I mean it doesn't work all the
time as we saw because um he lost to
Kalen in it
beat him
in I don't know
survive yeah yeah it might have helped
him survive but I mean ain't gonna help
him win fights does to the best of his
ability in that situation well it won't
let him go superhuman so I mean there's
only so much it can do for in a fight
like um he fires the FIA to save his
life but if he didn't have the f I mean
he would he might have he would have
lost would have died maybe actually so
he does everything possible that he can
do in that situation to live otherwise
he will otherwise he's he's sore out of
luck that's that's an interesting thing
that's going to be probably come back in
the season three just the ramifications
of that residual
guos by the way guys I see that a bunch
of people have are not talking in the
Discord have joined the Discord server
all of you guys who are watching if you
want to continue these kind of
conversations throughout the day not
when only when we're streaming you can
join our Discord server link is in the
description it's a free app um like
Twitter you just register your account
and then you can it's a chat room big
chat room so we talk about their about
stuff all the time about theories we
come up with ideas for future videos I
the Discord people are always the first
to know before a video comes out so
definitely join if you want to keep
chatting with us we're almost at like
400 people there on disc so we're uh
yeah we're growing quickly and we
definitely want to want you to be a part
of that because we've built an awesome
Community there we talk about we have
voice chat we talk on a daily basis
right so if you want to talk about this
kind of stuff more than just in the
Stream be sure to join the Discord and
yeah so we got some questions here
Tristan
says he doesn't think that Louch will
want to give people to guos because he
at the end him and suzaku come to the
conclusion that it's a bad thing true
that is true however you know that Louch
will do whatever it takes to get his
goals accomplished so I feel if Louch
needed to give someone guos in order for
that person to help him you know defeat
an enemy Louch would still do it because
for him the ends always justify the
means but that's just my own personal
opinion
um oh we got Nina X table [__] people
are asking if Nina X table [__] is going
to be confirmed in season 3 I know I
don't think so I think I think table can
do better you guys like he was he was
not a willing participant in that uh
exchange pray for table [__] guys re
remember Millie doesn't care if table
[__] seats other people she's got a
whole group of
furniture yeah he has an Ikea
store yeah there's a reason she's banned
in
Sweden Jeffrey Barnes ask what is c2's
real name and that we don't know Jeffrey
that's one of the biggest mysteries we
just don't know what her name is uh
someone had uh who was it was it Rohan
that had the idea that it could be
Brennan
or someone someone had the idea that it
could be Brennan
because in in U it's an Irish name that
means Celtic I guess um
that water drop
right alic
name meaning moisture or drop yeah so
that's
interesting because I think definitely
uh C2 could be Irish by by just the way
way
the like the church is designed in uh
the flashback of her childhood so I mean
that that for me would be a legitimate
Theory it could be that the Raindrop was
not even relevant that it was just like
a way to mask the sound but that I think
is still like something like that is a
legitimate Theory it's all we have to go
by so it's better than
nothing yeah but I mean the mythology of
G as well is Irish as well yeah
something like that CTIC defin okay so
beta reader is the one that said Brennan
so yeah good good idea bro and a random
person on the internet says is the
birthday Louch Oba thing Canon no it's
not it's [__] garbage it's not canon
I don't care what anyone says that's
trash is that the one where L comes back
as like a spirit for like one day yeah
well that's obviously complete Canon
that's totally not [__] they pull out of
their
butt oh man I need to see
that yeah go it's just a picture drama
that's what it is it's not even like an
anime or OVA it's just a picture
drama yeah that's what it is it was
released with the Blu-ray which is why
i' I'd like I'd think you know you can
get interesting
stuff no creep Ellen I can't notice you
I'm too busy no no Senpai no notice
that's a paradox
man just kidding of course and deep
voice says that he thinks C2 originates
from a Christian country yeah definitely
because we see her childhood remember we
see her as a child um in the vision and
she looks she's in a European country
the architecture there's like a church
the nun right so I would say it's a it's
a Catholic country I would say
France uh perhaps England because back
then it could have still been Catholic
or Ireland I like the Ireland idea
because guas is originally from Ireland
the architecture matches I think Irish
architecture but that's just my
opinion
zero I noticed you bro I noticed you I
gave you mod Powers I noticed
you no noasc asks if Alo the exiled
characters are in season 3 we not sure
but I think it's a possibility because
Leila from makido still has a valid
contract with C2 so it would seem weird
for them to just kind of leave that
alone and not actually make anything of
it so I think it's possible that Leila
and Akito at least show up in season
3 it
looks season 3 just all code contracts
have been magically cancelled and we get
to start
fresh is video Crobat gawk is here he
always he usually misses the stream
because he's busy on Saturdays but he's
here what's up bro as Soul would say
Crobat GK Crobat
GK G
deep voice says isn't England Protestant
yeah but only since like the 1400s or
something 1530 was when the Anglican
Church split from the Catholic one yeah
1530 and we know situ is like 700 years
old so she she would be even before
that
not sure Tristan what you mean people
giv guos can go versus code users um
they can they can kill a code user when
they have their guos fully developed yes
however they can't use their guos
against the code user
directly yeah so so that was a um anime
fan in the making that we saw on your
video or
what huh was that an anime fan in the
making we saw on your video oh yeah
definitely definitely uh we we do a um a
regular thing
um of Fridays we do
a we do a studio gibl movies family we
sit down that's nice that's very nice
begin the indoctrination early yes yeah
no but I mean studio gibl is the best
for the family I think yeah I mean so
long you're not watching grave fireflies
but yeah so long it's not that one then
yeah I think yes it's good it's good but
it's still like way more like if you
look at Princess monoke there's still
it's way more dark than most movies for
children but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean some of them some of them will go
over a child's head like um the princess
kaguya you know I mean that would would
go over a child's head the child
probably get bold with it but you know
as they get older they can then watch
those kind of ones they're more more
geared to
adult zoids BN is here what's up bro and
natu I noticed you natu is fired up
[Music]
um yes so there was something yeah the
Australia think no last a good point uh
Australia is an interesting mystery we
talked about it in other videos but it's
still an on mystery why is it separate
on every single map we can only
speculate we don't know Crobat also
mentions why do how how was ma able to
find C2 in the first place I just assume
that because he is so obsessed with her
that he was looking for her for years
reading people's minds and eventually
managed to somehow track her down that's
just my opinion I don't I don't I don't
think that there was some kind of
conspiracy involved with it he just kind
of was so obsessed and he put all his
energy into trying to find her for many
many years
you know they're linked code um code
users and their um gear spares are
linked uh we saw this with um V2s death
in O that the others noticed it and we
also see it with see to herself when
things happen with Louch or when certain
people like when n was taken and for
some reason she knew in it she was
connected and she
knew but yeah uh I don't know what it is
it's some weird kind of connection
between them yes
correct Jose junr asks super important
mystery how does C2 have natural green
hair and why is everyone so slender and
the answer to that is the magic of anime
bro the
magic that's that is no um no yeah
what's weird is um I'm thinking maybe
it's cuz she was so dirty as as a child
the um c2's hair was Brown when she was
very little but then after that her
hair's constantly
green yeah like plants started growing
and then they intertwined with the
normal hair and then it turned green
yeah something like that some kind of
weird now now we just need to figure out
how euphemia and Cornelia and like when
air got their hair
colors yeah because like pink and purple
and isn't isn't GW like a a silver pink
thing something like that
something are like the animation style I
don't think there's like too much oh
yeah I I also think so but it it's just
funny it's a clad only sunoh hara's hair
is like blonde and it's weird so he dies
it back to black even though people have
like purple or like
pink yeah yeah
yeah so yeah any other serious Mysteries
that you guys can think of right now I
got a few over here and we're going to
continue that chat uh on ORD Discord
we're gonna have a special chat room
just for ideas about Mysteries before we
make the video but yeah you have any
more ideas in the chat guys let us know
right now
because I'd love oh G in the chat said
Persia Persia Persia why is it
differently colored on the map and stuff
like that oh yeah pers yeah I I wonder I
someone said it was like a barrier
region or something right um I wouldn't
be
surprised like
between I don't know the Middle East
Federation and the Chinese
Federation does the Middle East even
have a federation does that mean
confirmed well it does it does at one
point because that's what Cornelia is
fighting before she um comes to Area 11
she's defeating that so it doesn't exist
after that
point yeah and and we do see camels like
so some kind of Middle East scenery in
the PV so maybe it plays a role G so
we'll see I I wrote it down for one of
my the options for the video so we could
maybe reference that the zoroastrians
are going to rise up and conquer the
world
obviously Jeffrey Barnes asks what guos
would Nali have
um absolute Tranquility something like
that maybe she already has absolute
control of freaking
oh yeah that's true it be the gears to
put everyone in
wheelchairs but yes heras would be like
everyone's just like
drugged Axel drugged around her just
like oh pretty flowers everyone's
peaceful and friendly the have that
simply because it sounds
hilarious the guos of friendship guys so
make people love each other yeah if she
she forces enemies to become friends and
stuff like that that's sounds like a
bad
that that would be so easy except in
that one euphemia got the power of
friendship uh zoids asks why did Lou and
shin have the same guas they did not
Shin's guas was specifically to kill to
make people he loves cares about kill
themselves or kill someone else that is
his guos it's not to control anyone and
it's just for that one specific purpose
yeah like his guos is never explained
but that seems to be what it what it
suggests it never had the
um never had the freedom of like open
commands in it yeah like it seems
limited and it didn't work against Leila
that I'm not sure if that was because of
her guos or because he didn't love her
so he couldn't use it on
her so that's another mystery we also
had a question about what do we think
would be the biggest cliche that could
happen in season 3 that's I'll open it
up to you guys I wonder what you guys
think clich anything along the lines of
power friendship saves the day and or
Lou becomes super op Mega hero that
fixes everything and makes it
perfect yeah like it appears that C2 and
luchia's relationships have developed
but if it regresses again to a Herm
point where he's just like there's all
these moments with all these different
girls that would be another cliche anime
thing to do oh yeah that's a good one
like yeah now we all obviously believe
Louch and C2 is a thing so if they now
go move move that back kind of like they
doing like School Rumble and stuff where
there's never any progress and now it's
like oh they're not actually a thing so
maybe he'll get with Colin maybe he'll
get with some like no please don't
freaking do that like that would be the
biggest cliche right there like there's
so many things going on between Louch
and C2 and then now they're not
together
stoping yeah it's beyond that point now
like there should be some consistency
there what the [__] Nicola milanich why
are you saying [__] you
man he's like you're not adequately
representing Serbian anime
fans the voice much love from balcon
States much love
bro yeah and uh rishab says that India
could play some role as well that is an
interesting concept because there is a
thought elevator in India and we do see
temples that look like Buddhist style
temples so could be India because of
course Buddhism comes from India
initially so that could be a hint in the
PV I mean they got to move on they got
to move Beyond Japan and China right
like they like that's where most of the
Original Series yeah place I'm
interested in Europe I'm very yeah I
want to see more of Europe yeah I
thought that was really cool the scenes
from Akito how they have the European
style buildings and the meccas fighting
within those contexts I wouldn't mind
seeing more of
that yeah in R2 Crobat says that India
was in an uprising against China so it
could be like a volatile region that
could uh become interesting yeah let's
see what what Serbia plays like if
Serbia plays are all that deep voice
says he has to go see you bro thanks for
coming out appreciate
it yeah it'll be interesting to see like
I don't even know yeah I don't think
Serbia even exists as an independent
country yeah they're part well except
you know not all members of the EU
joined the ufn like Germany's not a
member and I just want to know why
Germany's got its postor War two borders
in the codee guos
timeline because that stuff wouldn't I
don't know why it would do that in a
United Federation like the EU I anime
logic yeah I mean basically I think
that's the reason they were just too
lazy to think up a yeah it's probably
like reason if anyone argues it they'll
be like there was this completely
different event but had the same outcome
so yeah that that that's what will
happen if it's pushed but yeah I think
they were just lazy to differentiate
from the modern borders yeah they're
like this is not where we're going to
spend time let's develop them
characters Alexa says that she said that
she thinks one of the writers said that
Louch is not really attracted to C2 I
don't want to like hear rumors from
writers saying stuff like that because
writers should not be telling you what
characters how they behave that come out
from the actual show so writers should
never like I'm a writer myself I write
fiction and a writer should never tell
you this character is like this and that
character like that if you can't make
that come out in your own writing then
you shouldn't be saying anything because
you don't have the right to just decide
this character is this and this
character is that show it show it or
don't talk about it no ship sinking no
ship sinking
yes I personally think that Lou
definitely cared for Shirley and that he
would have dated her in if he didn't
think that he would put in danger if it
was a regular like high school anime
they probably would have gotten together
but it's not a slice of Life High School
anime yeah so in that sense I think he
had feelings for Shirley but he didn't
want to get close to her because of the
danger he posed for her and ultimately
obviously got her killed but C2 I think
the relationship will definitely develop
and that like I ship Lan C2 especially
them both being Immortal I ship them I
ship them
yeah what of civilization do you think
Tristan brings up do you think it's
still active right now do you think
there's still members of the ancient
civilization yeah that's a good question
way it was implied you know it's like an
instrumentality kind of deal where
everybody's gets absorbed I personally
don't think so if we're following along
the same thought line where they went
through the Ragnarok connection once
already and
descended then I personally don't think
that there's going to be
anyone of them left I'm just wondering
how how come some people would have
completed and been part of the human
instrumentality projectes situation but
other human beings remained like could
have like was is a choice like what why
would that happen that's what I'm
wondering well I mean the other part of
that that has me thinking as well is um
going back to Akito cuz uh the uh
representative of the Consciousness said
that like the humans were seen as like
not worthy in
it so if the humans are seen as not
worthy why then were they even accepted
into Ragnarok connection
yeah maybe it's yeah the question is um
whether whether the the ancient
civilization was human
or something else like Australians
right or always with the Australians yes
or whether you know a segment of that
Civilization did not join the egna
correction but because they didn't they
lost all the technology they lost all
that stuff and now their descendants are
modern humans so they're considered
different from the collective
Consciousness so that's the question
like like whether a segment of the angel
surviv to become the ancestors of modern
humans or whether humans are completely
separate from this ancient civilization
or is this civilization alien or did
they exist completely before humans even
evolved or like we don't know right but
it's an interesting question I'd make
another Stargate reference but I know
nobody would get
it I only I only watched the Stargate
movie like the original movie oh this
sg1 is so much better than the movie
just my personal opinion bro but Kurt
Russell
bro
I prefer the guy that they get
to any other Mysteries guys let me know
either in the chat or you guys are in
the
Stream and us were in
both my my my biggest mystery is like
why do some people get in inured so
badly and they survive and why some
people just get like one because PL
armor that's like a big m to
me the ultimate
defensive so you got shot in the arm I'm
done I'm
done yeah like if any of us got shot we
sure as heck wouldn't have plot armor
yeah we're not that important we we're
the background characters that are like
to bask in their
presence at least you got your dream at
least you're in an anime yeah I mean I
guess there's that small condolence
prize when we when we're one of the
people cut in the FIA but yeah at least
we got to be a background character for
like five seconds that's crazy too now
there's not gonna be a pen Dragon so
where not where's the like Capital gonna
be for
Britannia well they took back the
British Isles so they might move it back
to London I don't
know Tristan asks could there be a cult
uh dedicated to studying that ancient
civilization I think definitely like the
guos order is kind of
like is kind
of but could there could there be people
worshiping it in a religious way
absolutely as well temples were shown
right in the PV so we don't know there
might be some remnants of that
Civilization there might be a cult uh we
also had Vladimir cich is here what's up
bro uh he says what are your thoughts on
the skin Akito yeah that's a big mystery
we we already talked about it you might
have missed it but I'm going to talk
about that in the new video that will be
coming out uh next week or so the top
Mysteries unanswered mysteries in codas
that's one of them and I will be I'll
when I talk about these Mysteries I'll
give my own theories on them if I have
any um but obviously they're just going
to be speculation but I'll give you some
commentary in that video so then you'll
be able to see there what I think and
obviously let me know what you think in
the comments um anything else but yeah I
definitely want to make a cameo and R3
guys so if you need a if they need a
voice actor with a Eastern European
accent I'm there bro Russia Sushi yeah
Russia Russia plays a role in L so that
would be me I guess I could aim for a
Scandinavian
one yeah the anime dude says Arthur has
code that's the biggest plot twist
yes didn't we decide that it was going
to turn everyone into Neco that was what
arth's guos was it would be so funny if
like the guos creators like in all those
flashbacks with like C2 and stuff if
they just like put like Arthur in there
somewhere like we didn't notice but he's
just like
there Jose junor says Russians are
immune to guos that is a fact that is
true whatever they're eating then I want
it Crobat gox thinks I sound French
Canadian no I don't man you just don't
know what French Canadians sound
like interesting
Theory look he's special white red says
season 3 release we don't know yet we
have no concrete information yet bro all
we see in we've been watching the
official Japanese website for kodas and
all we're seeing is new merchandise
coming out like uh suzaku and Louch
jewelry um the the special Blu-ray disc
of the anniversary edition is coming in
April so yeah like all we're seeing is
new merchandise we're not seeing any
definitive dates if we did we would let
you know on this channel right away as
soon as we find out we will let you know
yeah we'll have a big video that says
news we got it's confirmed it's
confirmed and that's literally what the
whole thing the whole video will be it's
just you guys screaming it's confirmed
and then at the end there's the
date the last 20 seconds just five
minutes of crying and that it's here man
it's
fin link me that that video I haven't
seen it so I can't comment onbody if you
link it I can check it out
yeah so I think I think we're good for
now we can wrap this stream up uh slowly
uh if you guys want to continue the
conversation though join the Discord
Server Like I said there we uh chat all
the time if you want to check out Vector
maximus's Channel I put that in the
description as well he does some cool
gaming and uh map mods and stuff like
that including for code Gia so
definitely check him out show him some
love he supports us on the Discord
server all the time
um I ke ikc FW says Russians are not
immune to guas but V vodka is so that's
why they're immune they use the Vodka
everybody make sure to have your ration
of vodka
then
yeah koback gawk I'm not shouting you
out bro not shouting you no what's up oh
and Renee by the way I haven't shout out
Renee yet I see her a few times in the
chat what's up
Renee when I find she says when I find
out the release dat I will go batch it
crazy I know as soon as we find it out
we're going to go live on this channel
it's going to be called code GS breaking
news if we have a big news we're going
to go live so that we can tell you right
away and then we're going to make a
separate video announcing it but we're
going to go live right away so that like
we get it 10 minutes later we're live so
make sure you have all the notifications
on because we are going to go live and
let you know right away as soon as we
find something chat a bit we'll let you
know everything we know then we're gonna
upload a more formal video later but I
want to go live first because that's the
quickest way I don't have to do any
editing stuff like that we're just going
to go right away 10 minutes after we get
the news we're live on here talking to
you about the news and discussing it so
stay tuned for that absolutely I've said
it before and I'll said it again now
that you've said that they're going to
release it at like three o'clock in the
morning after you've had a really long
day who
cares it's like who cares it's who cares
damn it anime Recon I thought you were
not going to show up in this one but he
showed up to raid this stream too that's
so funny we were just about to
finish ah he got us he got us all right
guys thank you for coming everyone
thanks to Goen obviously uh thank he
didn't have a choice I made him come no
I always I love these things and part of
anime upro the crazy Oto girl hi we're
just wrapping up but thank you for
coming um thank you vector and soul Maka
for taking the time out of your day to
be here with us always a pleasure
chatting with you
guys thanks
always good for yeah absolutely and yes
guys so if you want to continue the chat
you can come into the Discord server um
again it's totally free no one makes any
money from that it's just because we
want to build the community on there uh
also uh new video new code guos video
about blue guas coming up coming out
today later today as soon as Goen is
done editing so watch out for that be
ready and in Discord I will let you know
right before it comes out so if you're
in the Discord you'll be the first to
know right before it comes out you can
be the first to watch you can be the
first to comment first and that makes
you best girl so keep that in mind and
yeah until next time thank again thanks
again for coming and being a part of
this discussion we love talking with you
guys and until next time see y space
Cowboys
Bang